[Music]
from a nine-year-old singing sensation
to a 12 year old ventriloquist
[Music]
America's Got Talent might have another
winner on their hands who's not even old
enough to vote need more proof
check out 15 year old magician Henry
Richardson the Brooklyn native left the
judges stunned with his sleight of hand
now with my cards here in your card
there let's try something maybe I can
get my card to travel to your hand and
yours - mine take a peek
oh my gosh but that's not all he had up
his sleeve Simon if you'd hold out one
of your hands and sandwich your other
hand right on top lift up to only one
page all right got one I'm gonna take
that from you now do me a favor and just
imagine whatever image you just saw
floating in the air written on a small
little slip of paper no right through
the top I want you to tear that in half
tear it in half seriously these you're
gonna find in between the layers of
cardstock
Simon's soccer ball we'll see if Henry's
epic card trick lands him a spot in the
next round
when AGT continues Tuesday night on NBC
[Applause]
[Music]
you